[Musique]
le girly et retirent a été conçu pour
permettre la promotion du tir sportif au
féminin il a regroupé des jeunes filles
et des dingues allant de de l'âge de 8
ans jusqu'à 70 ans ce qui est ce qui est
quand même assez conséquent nous avons
eu 40
personne licenciée au sein de
différentes associations du 68 où elles
ont pu pratiquer en tout me dire qu'on
vit
[Musique]
pandey des connaissances le
développement du du tir
beaucoup ont appris à tirer juste en
loisirs et le fait de faire une petite
compétition rien contre eux fille a
comme qui dirait permis à ces jeunes à
ces jeunes oies ces dames de faire une
compétition et donc de se lancer ensuite
dans la compétition pour connaître les
futures dates du girly et retire et
notamment gallia et retire 2019 je vous
invite à venir sur visitez le site de la
ligue tir alsace.fr sur lequel vous
découvrirez notamment différentes
petites rubriques sur le sport au
féminin et le sport le tir sportif au
féminin et toutes les autres disciplines
qui sont présentes dans le tir sportif